we've been seeing these tiny little
glasses all over Tick Tock so I knew I
had to get ducky a pair these frames are
from the Paw wag company and they're
12.99 I got him two frames one in a size
small and one in a size medium to see
which ones would fit me better these
ones are the size small it's the round
glasses in Black I think they're so
stinking cute on him it also comes with
a connector that helps the glasses stay
on his face
[Music]
dog glass does the dog need glasses did
you take them to LensCrafters and he got
an eye exam and no probably not because
he has no vision problem at all I assume
right he's not visually disabled you're
basically you're forcing him to live
like that you're forcing a a trans-abled
identity on this poor dog because you
think glasses are cute
as a visually impaired American myself
you see these these glasses this is not
for show I need these I have special
eyes I just want to say my culture
is not a damned costume for a dog you
bigot